guys we have huge news Earth shattering
news the saddest news uh yeah so uh for
those of you that don't know on YouTube
I am currently working on like an
obnoxiously Long Dragon Ball series and
that series is taking a lot more time
than I thought it was going to attack
the first two parts for the Saiyan Saga
and the Frieza Saga are up right now uh
but we're currently working in the cello
Saga I said that it was going to be done
uh today if you're seeing this video at
the 12th of August but uh it's not done
it's uh it still needs a bit more time
in the oven and because of that we gotta
give more time to it and so we're going
to say that it's going to be next
Saturday so Saturday the 19th I'll leave
the the date actual here I think it's
the 19th and uh yeah that's when you can
expect that video and after that would
move on to the the boo Saga so sorry for
the delay but uh hopefully the video
will be worth it and I hope you look
forward to it thanks guys